before I take your questions I'd like to
share just a few brief opening comments
all of us at Boeing are deeply sorry for
the loss of life in the ethiopians
Airlines flight 302 and Lion Air flight
610 accidents we feel the immense
gravity of these events and we recognize
the devastation to the families and
friends of the loved loved ones who have
perished there is nothing more important
to us than the safety of the people who
fly on our airplanes every day 5.3
million people fly safely on Boeing
airplanes on average more than 2,900 737
airplanes are in the air with nearly
half a million passengers on board at
any given time and a 737 takes off
around the world or lands roughly every
1.5 seconds through the work we are
doing now in partnership with our
customers and regulators to certify and
implement the software update the 737
max will be one of the safest airplanes
ever to fly we've been in constant
contact with our customers and listening
to their needs to ensure that the fleet
is maintained appropriately and
positioned for an efficient return to
service once cleared for passenger
flights our teams will take an entry
into service approach with every plane
returning service which includes
deploying teams to all of our Macs
operators and providing dedicated
real-time operational support we also
will be providing enhanced training and
supplemental education materials for our
airline customers pilots Boeing has an
important role to play in advancing
training efforts that support safe
operations in addition to the software
upgrade that we are working on we're
also committed to going above and beyond
on training and while we focus on the
safe return to service of the Macs the
fundamentals of our market and our
business remain strong I want to thank
our team for their ongoing focus on
safety quality and integrity with that
I'll be happy to take your questions
then if you've said a couple of times we
own it
what mistakes do you own you've also
mentioned that you will earn and re earn
trust there are a lot of passengers who
are afraid of the max why should they
trust Boeing that it will be safe with
this upgrade David I think first of all
again our commitment to safety is
unwavering and we do regret the impact
that this has had to the passengers we
know we do have work to do to earn and
rerun that trust and we will I will say
to the first part of your question as
we've been part of both investigations
we've been very diligent about
respecting the integrity of the
investigation process throughout and
providing technical technical support
we know that in both accidents there was
a chain of events that occurred one of
the links in that chain was the
activation of the M caste system because
of erroneous angle-of-attack data that
was a common link in both accidents we
know that we can break that link in the
chain that is a link that we own it's
our responsibility to eliminate that
risk and the software update does
exactly that so we're focused on taking
care of that and getting the max back up
and flying safely we're going to be
working very closely with our airline
customers and with the FAA and with
regulatory authorities around the world
as we finish up the certification
process on the software update and have
safe re-entry into service we're going
to be diligently doing that airplane by
airplane with our customers I think
getting it back up and flying is
obviously a key step in rebuilding
confidence and then we'll be working
with our airline customers over time to
ensure they have the support they need
and that we rebuild public confidence as
the fleet gets back up and operating
mistake a design mistake well what we've
seen is we've looked at the MKS
activation this erroneous angle attack
information that came into the airplane
we've also gone back and taken a look at
the design of the MKS system itself the
original design we've confirmed that it
was designed per our standards certified
per our standards and we're confident in
that process
so it operated according to those design
and certification standards so we
haven't seen a you know a technical slip
or gap in terms of the fundamental
design and certification of the approach
that said we know this is a link in both
accidents that we can break
that's a software update that we know
how to do we own it and we will make
that update and this will make the
airplane even safer going forward and
I'm confident with that change it will
be one of the safest airplanes ever to
fly hello in the light of the crisis
facing your company and in the interests
of Rio nning the trust of the flying
public
have you considered resigning I think
the important thing here again is we're
very focused on safety and I can tell
you that both of these accidents weigh
heavily on us as a company I've had the
privilege of working for the Boeing
Company for 34 years and we know that
lives depend on what we do we take that
very very seriously
and I've had the privilege of doing that
for my entire career and I can tell you
that our Boeing employees as well take
that very seriously
and so I'm very focused on safety going
forward it's important that as a company
we have those clear priorities that
we're taking the right actions that we
have the right culture I am strongly
vested in that and my clear intent is to
continue to lead on the front of safety
and quality and integrity that's who we
are as a company and I think it's really
important to continue to stress that you
know we we deeply regret what happened
with these accidents it gets to the core
of our company I've had the chance to
walk the factory floors in Renton where
we build the Macs airplanes over the
last few weeks I've had a chance to talk
with our test pilots I've had the
opportunity to talk with our engineers
to the core of our people they care
about this business and the safety of
our airplanes that's what I'm focused on
mr. wollenberg this is the first
opportunity we've had to talk to you
since this unfolded why did you put an M
caste system in place in the plains
without notifying the airlines or the
pilots and why did you not tell the
pilots that the angle-of-attack disagree
warning light was deactivated well let
me take those two questions on to two
answers here first of all we take a look
at the original design of the M caste
system I think in some cases in the
media it's been reported or described as
an anti stall system which it is not
it's a system that's designed to provide
handling qualities for the pilot that
meet pilot preferences we want the
airplane to behave in the air similar to
the previous generation of 737s that's a
preferred pilot feel for the airplane
how it feels as they're flying it and M
caste is designed provide those kind of
handling qualities at high angle of
attack so it's a purposeful design it's
something that is designed to be part of
how the airplanes fly so as part of the
certification process it's not something
that's a separate procedure or something
that needs to be trained on separately
is fundamentally embedded in the
handling qualities of the airplane and
so when we train on the airplane you're
being trained on M caste it's not a
separate system to be trained on to your
second question on on angle of attack
sensor information certainly we've been
taking a look at some of the reports
that are out even again today taking a
look at the design of that original
system again I can confirm for you that
going forward that angle of attack
disagree signal is something that will
be standard on all of the 737 maxes
we'll also be looking at retrofitting
that on all of the airplanes and that
will be provided at no cost I think
that's an important step forward it's
also important to understand that that
angle of attack disagree signal in the
cockpit is not something that drives
pilot action it's not something that we
design in as a primary flight display in
the flight deck of a commercial airplane
what pilots care about are things like
altitude airspeed heading pitch and roll
that's what they fly those indicators
are in the flight deck today airspeed
and altitude in particular are the
relevant items or
these two cases those are signals that
are in the cockpit today those are
things that provide audible warnings to
the pilot as well including things like
stick shaker and so that's where we
focus on the training effort going
forward sir if I can you've said that
the EM cast system the angle of attack
connecting it to just one sensor that
met your process and yet the fact that
it's only plugged into one sensor and
could fail seems really like something
that should have been foreseen when you
talk about re-establishing credibility
with fliers you know they are reading
about reports that whistle blow after
whistle blower have come forward to the
FAA and to Congress to say that there
were problems with the with a
certification process there were
concerns about EM Cass you had stopped
short of saying that there was a mistake
made in the in the process how do you
win back trust when there are some that
feel you have a real credibility issue
when you when Boeing has not come out
and said you know we didn't do this
right yeah I think those are very fair
questions again and we've again probed
on those same questions ourselves we've
gone back and looked at at both
accidents we've done deep assessments or
airplane and the design and we've
confirmed that the um caste system as
originally designed did meet our design
and safety analysis criteria and our
certification criteria those are
standard processes that have worked for
decades and will continue to work now
that said when we design a system
understand that these airplanes are
flown in the hands of pilots and in some
cases our system safety analysis
includes not only the engineering design
but also the actions that pilots would
take as part of a failure scenario right
that's all baked into a system and and
analysis now that all said going forward
we've identified a way to improve this
is to make it a dual sensor feed that is
a change that we're making with the
software update and I'm confident that
again will create an airplane as one of
the safest in the air to fly you said
that it's you it's operated as designed
you couldn't have possibly designed a
system that would activate 21 times
pushing the nose with a plane down to
the point of an unrecoverable dive again
if you take a look at the end end system
procedure that's assigned with this so
in the case of a M cast failure scenario
there's something called a runaway
stabilizer procedure which is a memory
item in the cockpit if that kind of
scenario occurs and you go through the
checklist and again that checklist was
published as part of the recent
Ethiopian preliminary report if you look
through that checklist it calls out
actions that would be taken around power
management and pitch management of the
airplane it also refers to the cut out
switches that after an activation that
was not pilot induced that you would hit
the cutoff switches and in some cases
those procedures were not completely
followed so the pilot struggled with
that process either recognizing what was
happening or implementing those those
steps the first line air flight it was a
jump seat captain who told the fight for
what to do and the second one it doesn't
appear that they did that at all the
Ethiopian folks generally followed that
checklist we're not able to recover so
does that mean that does that mean that
didn't were you overly confident in
pilot's abilities given this
circumstance particularly an they didn't
know em Cass was there in the first
place yeah I'll go back to my previous
comment as we look at both accidents and
this is common to most airplane
accidents that have occurred over
history there's a chain of events there
are multiple contributing factors there
are factors that we can control in the
design and in this case that common link
related to the EM caste system and its
activation
we're gonna break that link and this
will prevent accidents from life from
this like this from happening again
yes that's an important state part where
the accident happened without em Cass
though you call it a link it's a chain
of events right there is no singular
item it's a chain of events I think it's
really important that we all focus on
letting the investigation process run
its due course our job is to focus on
safety not on speculation we're gonna
continue to support the investigation
process and I would suggest that that is
the right way to handle this in the long
run this industry is safe because of the
integrity of the safety process and the
way these investigations are done it's a
continuous improvement process
that over the last couple of decades has
continued to dramatically improve air
safety it is the safest form of
transportation in the world because of
the integrity of the process and we're
going to support the integrity to that
process and we're going to make sure the
max is the safest airplane out there to
fly a lot of airlines have lost a lot of
money because of the grounding of the
Mexican you say anything about how
you're going to compensate them for that
we're actively engaged with all of our
airline customers and again we we deeply
regret the impact to their operations
and their customers I know it's
difficult I personally talked to many of
our customers and I can tell you our
team is out deployed with the customers
on a daily basis I won't comment on
individual discussions by airline but we
understand the difficulty is that this
is cost I will say our partnerships with
our airline customers are strong and
we're gonna be working together on
recovery efforts the first focus here is
safely getting the max back up and
flying and then we'll address the
follow-on issues Dennis
today again you've repeated this message
that the certification process and the
design process for M Cass was followed
as per usual consistent with what you've
done but forget about the process the
final design of M Cass was deeply flawed
and your engineers are fixing it and
testing the fix today fixing very
specific flaws which are clear in the
flights so can you admit that the design
was flawed nevermind the processes you
went through it and you did the best you
could but what you came up with in the
end was flawed was it not we've designed
the Macs to have the flying qualities
that were desired in the hands of the
pilots yum Cass system is part of that
design effort we have gone back and
confirmed again as we do the safety
analysis the engineering analysis that
we followed exactly the steps and our
design and certification processes that
consistently produce safe airplanes now
in in this case again as you know most
accidents they're a chain of events that
occur
it's not correct to attribute that to
any single item we know there are some
improvements that we can make to M cast
and we will make those improvements but
the reason this industry is safe is that
we never stop on making safety
improvements we never claim that we have
reached the endpoint we are continuously
across all of our airplane programs
improving safety every day we always
look for opportunities for to improve
that culture that's unafraid to go make
safety improvements over time that
culture is what is driven this to be an
incredibly safe industry that is our
commitment we're not going to waver from
that we're not going to step back from
that we will continually look for
opportunities to improve safety that's
our responsibility and that's part of
rearing that trust that I talked about
earlier people die can you answer a few
questions here about that